Hãy chừng Yvang Sede Abbas Arachin, ngày 20, tổng báo, thật thận Cairo, kỳ hồi tháng chính giới vàng và IAA đã chính thức chấm rất thử lực.
Cuối định đứa ra sau khi IAa thông qua một nghị quyết, yêu cầu từ Yvang báo cáo tình chẳng trữ lượng của Hòi Nhi,
văn hiện giống Mỹ của pháp anh và đức để sốt, IVang Châu Giang,
kiếc nãy không phủ hợp với các thử chỉ của IAAa, đồng thời làm suy yếu sức nập lập và tính chuyên môn của các quan giám rất thần nhận.
Bộng ở dưới văn thẳng định đã gửi thư chính thức tới tổng giám lắm IAa,
thông báo thật thận Cairo không còn giả chị.
Tên IVang có đây là phản lưỡng cần thiết, sau khi IAa tích tổng gây xe két,
cho bối cảnh IVang vẫn suy chỉ lập trường rằng các quan này cần tôn chẳng quân khổ pháp li hiện hành.
Chuy đó IVang đã tạm đình chỉ hấp tán với IAa và thẳng sấu,
nhằm sản đối phản những cuộc các quan này đối với các cuộc tấn công nhằm và cơ sở hạn nhân của họ.
Thật họn Cairo tương được ki vọng dưỡng lại thánh chà,
nhưng sẽ biến mở này cho thấy hợp tán giãi bên tức đội mặt như trường ai.